[Music]
playing in the paint I see it's my
favorite place to draw fouls why are you
still here I thought your Bannerman left
long ago do you think they can make it
home without you to carry them how about
a quick duel James one on one just like
old times I don't have time for your
games Brodie some of us are still in the
playoffs
you're right I'd hate to break those
second most valuable ankles before your
next series are you coming to my car so
with so much ass ASSA do your worst
[ __ ] very nice a double Shem got it to
the answers crossover impressive
actually that was always oh sorry I was
supposed to let you get the rebound
right now this move here I used it for
my 22nd triple da I use this one for my
42nd I don't know why you don't come to
Houston more often you clearly love to
travel
oh this from a man who leads the league
in turnovers not anymore
[Music]
[Music]
game point James time to show off those
renowned defensive skills ah
but actually my defense is much improved
in fact if you look at their numbers you
will see that I contested over 8 shots
per game third most amongst guards we
could have had a duel James if you and
the serpent hadn't slithered away
okay Ross like this isn't what you
wanted all in all to finally be done man
or the triple doubles the realm MVP now
he does what he wants right everything
except tween now if you excuse me I have
to get my ass kicked by the sparrows and
[Applause]
get his ass kicked
they did though sir beard and his
bannermen won the first battle House
Spurs proved too strong vanquish
in-house Rockets in six games elsewhere
and West's house Warriors made quick
work of the Brotherhood with one banner
and sent house to a swift demise when
the pop king in the soulless army tried
to stop them they found Silva was no
match for gold over in the east the
hammer of Akron smashed rebellions from
house paces and Canadians all eyes
turned to the one seat but the king of
the forth proved merely the king of
fourth place and so it was written King
James and the champions of war
against the most powerful house the
realm has ever seen okay well maybe
second second house first
obviously sir Jordan is 96 Bulls well
some say it's the Bulls but others argue
it's the Showtime dynasty right here in
Los Angeles
how do we become a dynasty again Lord
magic I want to become a dynasty well
the first step is to trade all the
little buggers who send into propria
ravens then we sign big time free agents
like Paul George and thirdly we build
through the draft
[Music]
yes from the flyer you are born my
little nuns oh the triad of Falls would
make the realm shake glossy and get us
are 1 billion gold
[Music]
that's my boy
[Music]
[Music]
you